wallen mohammedi géo politologue
spécialiste du monde arabe
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous peu
d'informations au final sur la
mobilisation d'aujourd'hui à alger dans
les autres villes du pays
sur le terrain si vous possédez des
informations des remontées en termes de
participation notamment
oui alors les informations que j'ai
indiquent des manifestations massives je
pense que c'est peut-être l'une des
manifestations les plus massives depuis
le début du direct et je pense que c'est
une véritable démonstration de force
une réponse qui s'adresse à l'avoir
pouvoir algérien de lui même à ceux qui
ont prédit l'essoufflement du mouvement
est aussi vous observateurs qui se sont
finalement lassé
2 du soulèvement populaire donc oui les
deux des informations que j'ai les
manifestations aujourd'hui ont été
particulièrement massif ce qui reflète
une véritable détermination du peuple
adjoint thomas on l'a dit ce sera le
premier anniversaire du direct en un an
quel bilan est ce qu'on peut tirer
qu'elle avançait quels défis encore à
relever
oui alors effectivement on est quand
même dans un contexte d'anniversaire je
pense qu'ils les deux principaux risques
finalement c'est à la fois la
routinisation est là et la muséification
du mouvement c'est pas de parler par
exemple de célébrations et c'est alors
qu'on a quand même à faire un véritable
soulèvement populaire qui se poursuit le
bilan est mitigé alors du côté du peuple
algérien le bilan est positif parce
qu'on a une réappropriation de la chose
politique par les algériens
on a une déstabilisation du pouvoir
algérien qui a été révélé par les
manifestations
mais on a aussi un pouvoir algérien qui
est là qui semble presque
indéboulonnable et qui surveillait donc
le bilan il doit être fait dans les
dents les dans les deux sens il ya d'un
côté la révolution qui a qui a apporté
beaucoup de choses à l'algérie qui a
apporté beaucoup de choses au peuple
algérien qui s'est retrouvée qui s'est
réconcilié qui refait de la politique ce
qui est une bonne chose mais d'un autre
côté on va faire une contre révolution
qui a elle-même a porté ses résultats ce
qui est la meilleure preuve est la
survie du régime algérien qui reste
finalement intacte tenir il ya une
rupture au niveau de la société
algérienne il n'y a aucune rupture au
niveau du pouvoir john parler de la
routinisation 2
ce mouvement du ra qui manifestaient
dans les rues ce qu'il ya d'autres
façons de
de se faire entendre non la vraie
question c'est la question de l'ampleur
c'est à dire que la routinisation
c'était ça veut dire laisser une partie
des algériens manifestaient de
manifester indéfiniment et on va dire
conserver une sorte de majorité
d'attentiste non le la manifestation la
pression populaire et tuée est un outil
incontournable et cet outil a été saisie
par les algériens le 22 février 2019
mais il faut évidemment amplifié ce
mouvement là qu'elle génère pour le
mouvement
la suite pour le mouvement pour moi il
répond tout de suite à la question de la
de la fameuse structuration du mouvement
est ce qu'il faut qu'il soit structuré
et c'est pour moi c'est un faux débat
parce qu'il ne peut pas s il n'a pas
vocation à structurer parce qu'un
mouvement structuré c'est un mouvement
phagocyté par le régime algérien
en tunisie on n'a pas eu besoin d'un
parti d'un mouvement d'un jeune
structure pour poussé ben ali à la fuite
non là la clé c'est convaincre les
algériens la majorité des algériens
d'amplifier le mouvement parce que la
pression populaire peu et je pense que
le meilleur moyen finalement de
renverser le régime algérien qui est
l'objectif initial du peuple algériens
abdelmadjid teboul nouveau président qui
a été élu en décembre dernier a parlé il
ya cinq jours du irak béni est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir une
une main tendue un dialogue une façon de
de dialoguer entre le mouvement d'un
côté le gouvernement de l'autre non
honnêtement je ne vois pas de dialogue
possible
je prends l'exemple tunisien parce que
parfois cet exemple et dédaigné par un
certains observateurs parce qu'il
considère que la situation est encore
difficile mais politiquement les
tunisiens ont au moins réussi une chose
c'est à dire se débarrasser du régime
pénal et donc les algériens ne peux
faire la même chose je ne vois pas de
dialogue possible monsieur tom boon
c'est la vitrine de la contre-révolution
c'est là c'est là c'est laisser
l'apparatchik par excellence c'est
l'homme issu de régime c'est l'ancien
premier ministre de boutef n'efface et
du goûter ce n'est pas moribond c'est à
dire le complice de l'humiliation
infligée aux algériens donc je ne vois
pas de main tendue et j'ai envie de dire
que la main tendue est d'autant plus
difficile que qu'on a encore à faire des
opposants qui croupissent en prison pour
atteinte au moral de l'armée c'est à
dire atteinte au moral de quelques
généraux donc je ne vois pas du tout de
même attendu monsieur t'abonner est dans
la continuité c'est celle 1 alors
omnipotent traits assez peu avec des
pouvoirs très limités ou mais c'est la
vitrine du pouvoir militaire algérien
aujourd'hui on a dit donc manifestation
d'ampleur aujourd'hui veille du premier
anniversaire le jour j c'est demain ce
qu'il ya des manifestations de prévu
également demain honnêtement je ne sais
pas du tout la grande manifestation à
lui aujourd'hui c'est une c'est une
manifestation qui lance le lan 2
dudu et lacs du mouvement populaire
algérien je pense qu'il y aura d'autres
manifestations il y aura peut-être des
rassemblements demain il y aura des
événements certainement demain mais
l'objectif des algériens c'est de donner
un nouveau souffle en fait un faux
mouvement populaire c'est de pousser le
de réussir à susciter de nouvelles
vocations a poussé le mouvement
populaire a s'amplifient c'est ça
l'objectif
le on en fait ce qui n'a pas changé on
la nomme finalement c'est le rapport de
force entre la population algérienne et
le pouvoir algérien si pouvoir algérien
est toujours là ce n'est pas parce que
le frac n'est pas structurée parce que
les algériens ont commis des erreurs
c'est parce qu'il n'a pas l'intention de
partir parce que les ailes les
dirigeants algériens qui gouverne encore
aujourd'hui clandestinement veulent
rester en place merci demain à midi
d'avoir éperonné une question réplique
que vous êtes tg au politologue
spécialiste du monde arabe